- Social media is bursting
with cool stories,
you may miss in this shuffle,
but I will not let you miss the best.
This is what I'm liking.
(crowd cheering)
This one speaks to what the
New York spirit is all about.
When "Fat Bike" Phil came
across an abandoned guitar,
near a pile of trash in hell's kitchen,
he was sure no one would
intentionally throw it away.
He looked inside
and found it had the name of
the owner, Daniel Martinez.
So, "Fat Bike" Phil set out on a mission.
He hoisted the guitar on
his back, pedaled at home,
and set out to find Daniel.
With some great detective
work, he figured it out.
But that's just where the story begins.
We have "Fat Bike" Phil
and Daniel on the line.
What's up gentlemen?
(crowd cheering)
- Hey Kelly.
- Hi, how are you?
- So, Phil, you found the
guitar just in time, right?
- Kelly, it had been raining
like crazy in the city
and I was out on my bike.
And I'm riding around during
the break in the rain.
I saw this guitar case leaning
against the scaffolding
next to this huge pile of garbage.
And so, I went and I investigated.
I looked inside
and I saw that there was an
acoustic guitar in there.
And I don't know,
just the guitar player in
me couldn't abandon it.
So, I put it on my back
and took it back with me,
and opened it up,
and realized this is a
very expensive guitar.
Somebody is crushed right now.
I called up my wife on the phone
and we found some stuff
in the guitar case.
I called her up.
We did some sleuthing,
and we found Daniel on Facebook
playing that same guitar.
So, we knew we had our guy.
- Aw, man.
(crowd cheering)
Well, Daniel, that guitar
means the world to you, right?
So, how do you feel?
- I feel grateful.
I feel fortune because
the guitar is like a part
or extension of your body.
So, even if I get another guitar,
it's never going to be the same.
It's like, if a part of you is cut out.
Even if you replaced it,
it's not gonna be the same.
So, I feel good.
I feel grateful.
And when I met Phil,
it was amazing that he was a musician too.
So, God is good all the time.
(Kelly laughs)
I feel grateful.
- I would watch this show by the way.
You two are awesome
together. (everyone laughs)
So wait, Phil and Daniel, can
you play a little for us now?
- Of course, yes.
- Danny, let's do something
in A minor. Ready?
- Okay.
- One, two, three, let's go.
(mellow acoustic music)
- Yeah!
(crowd cheering)
Oh my God, I love that.
Thank you so much, Phil and Daniel.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
All right, well, that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
the go to pen at the Kelly Clarkson show,
thinks that your story is
as incredible as we do.
And in recognition, they'd
like to write you each a check
with their G2 gel ink pen for $500.
Together, that's a $1,000.
All just for you.
(crowd cheering)
- [Daniel] Thank you.
- [Kelly] Thank you guys so much.